foreign
how can we help
oh hi Ken hi George I was just in the
studio yesterday and I appreciate you
taking my phone call Fantastic how can
we help yeah yeah so I'm 25 years old
I'm currently on baby stop number three
and
I'm looking for a career change I'm
burnt out of my job I've been applying
for jobs and interviewing and also
considering a relocation I currently
rent right now I live alone and I paid
month to month and I was thinking about
moving back home with my parents just to
save some money maybe
to save up my emergency fund and
hopefully save enough money to make a
down payment on a mortgage so what would
this time period be how long would that
be to accomplish what you just laid out
so I could theoretically move in with my
parents I could probably
pay for next month's rent and then move
out in November and then hopefully I
would find a new job Within six months
to a year
Are You Gonna Keep your current job
um yeah for the time being I will yeah
why wait a year to find a new job
well I I'm currently looking for a job
right now hopefully it wouldn't be a
year I think you're answering my
question on how long you would live with
Mom and Dad somewhere between six months
two years is that right
yeah that's correct yeah I mean I don't
have a problem with it if it helps you
save money
um and it's for a short season I'm not a
fan of you moving back in long term
obviously and I don't think that's what
you're saying but I've got no problem
with that what's your rent today
my rent is about twelve hundred dollars
and what's your take-home pay
um I make 44 Grand okay and so we would
you be paying something to Mom and Dad
what's that going to look like
um well I'm an only child I mean they
wouldn't ask for any money
um
that was the answer I think that's her
I'm the only child like they're gonna be
thrilled to have you back yeah when you
talk to them about this or is this is
this going to be a surprise to them
I'm sure they wouldn't mind me moving
back in with them for uh okay for a
short period of time yeah I think as
long as it's a short period of time you
aren't paying a lot of rent right now
comparatively to your take-home pay so
if you are gonna stay where you're at
you need to get a roommate in order to
speed up your financial goals
yes that's right all right so is that
the big question there do we have a was
there another one about the work
it sounds like you don't really know
what you want to do
well
I I do and I don't you know I work uh in
healthcare I'm a recreation therapist I
currently work in a memory care facility
and
um I kind of know it's not for me but I
would like to
stay in my field
I'm also a writer I wrote a book and I
told you it's a very important book so
what's the latter look like for staying
in therapy
um well currently I'm applying for
government jobs and hopefully getting to
a VA okay and um I would make a little
bit more money but not a whole lot more
money
so why why government my VA
um just because it's
uh a better job than than where I'm at
right now yeah but I would think that
that you could do much better in therapy
uh if I'm understanding the type of
therapy that you're doing it would seem
that there is a much better opportunity
uh in the private sector am I right
um there could be
it's different things it's my job is
recreation therapy so I do sort of
leisure-based therapies for people with
disabilities to help right improve the
quality of their lives well here's what
I'm going to challenge you to do I'm
going to challenge you because you said
I want to stay in my field and I would
say yes that's a good idea to look at
therapy in general but I would go okay
you got recreational therapy and what
are the limits there what in other words
what are the lids
in that occupation and then let's look
at other types of things where there
might be some additional qualification
that you need to get but would allow you
to climb higher and make more money I
really want to challenge you and push
you on this not just assume well I'm
going to go work for the government you
know and again I'm I'm
it's very hard George to advance in
government work it just is I mean in the
with the private sector this is much
greater opportunity the ceiling is a lot
higher over there and making 44 in
healthcare in New York I think you can
do a lot better A lot better so we're
pushing you a little bit uh Andrew I
want to get you in that house and it's
going to take a lot longer making 44
than 84. I want the bigger shovel is how
we use that term that means more income
and it's fast forwarding everything so
there you go